- It's my pleasure today
to welcome you to this
webinar from YPSA,
the Yale Program for the
Study of Anti-Semitism.
My name is Jeff Alexander
and I'm professor
of sociology here at Yale
and a board member of YPSA.
It's my honor and privilege
as well as a real personal
pleasure to welcome my friend
and colleague Chad Goldberg,
to speak today.
Chad is the Martindale-Bascom
Professor of Sociology
at the University of Wisconsin at Madison,
and the author of many articles
and important books of
original research and theory.
But before telling you
about some of these,
I wanna tell you how Chad describes
his research areas on
Wisconsin Sociology website.
He describes them as quote,
modern Jewish thought,
especially social and political thought,
the civil incorporation of
Jews as an ethno-religious
minority in relation to modern
state and nation building
and the sociology of anti-Semitism.
I'm reading you this
because I can assure you
that it's most unusual, as far as I know,
Chad is the only sociologist
at a leading American
department to describe
his research specialties
as devoted entirely to what was once
called the Jewish question.
In fact, Chad's first book was not
about Jews but about workers.
It was entitled "Citizens
and Paupers: Relief, Rights,
and Race, from the Freedmen's
Bureau to Workfare",
and it won some important awards.
It was in the years after that publication
that Chad began attending
to matters concerning Jewish
exclusion and incorporation.
One line of which culminated
in his singular book,
modernity and the Jews in Western thought,
it was a finalist for the
National Jewish Book Award
and the Jordan Schnitzer Book Prize
and the winner of several prizes
from sociological societies.
Chad has been a fellow at
some of the world's most
distinguished institutes
for advanced studies,
including the Princeton Institute,
the Hanse-Wissenschaftskolleg in Berlin,
and the Max Weber Kolleg in Erfurt.
He's also been the George
L. Mosse visiting professor
at the Hebrew University in Jerusalem.
Today I welcome Chad to speak at Yale.
This talk, as you know,
is entitled From Multiculturalism
to Antisemitism Revisiting the
Jewish Question in America.
Chad?
- Jeff, thank you so much.
I wanna thank you and
I wanna thank Maurice
for the opportunity to take
part in this webinar today.
Jeff, I wanna thank you for
that very kind introduction
and I wanna thank all of the attendees
who are here to participate as well.
It's a personal and professional pleasure
to be here with all of you today.
I'm gonna go ahead and see
if I can share my screen
with you and let me go
ahead and get started.
My point of departure today
is Jeff's work actually,
which has had a strong influence on me
and specifically his 2006
book, the Civil Sphere.
Those of you who have read
this book know that nearly 90
pages of its 550 pages are
devoted to the Jewish question.
As Jeff shows,
the Jewish question arose
in both Europe and America,
but in these settings,
the instabilities of Jewish incorporation
were resolved in markedly different ways.
I can't do justice in
my presentation today
to Jeff's lengthy comparison
of the Jewish question
in Europe and America,
but sufficed to say that his discussion
of the Jewish question in
Europe concludes with the Shoah,
while the corresponding
discussion of the Jewish question
in America ends with the
emergence in the 1960s
of a multicultural mode
of Jewish incorporation.
The startling resurgence of antisemitism
in the United States and the
last several years raises
a host of questions about the rich
and insightful discussion
of the Jewish question
that we find in the civil sphere.
If American Jews have been
the beneficiaries of a
multicultural mode of
incorporation since the 1960s,
how do we account for the
resurgence of antisemitism?
Does it mean that Jeffrey
Alexander's assessment
of the Jewish question in
America was overly sanguine?
Alternatively, if the assessment
was correct for roughly half a century
from the 1960s until the 2010s,
does the resurgence of
antisemitism indicate another shift
in civil discourse that is
bringing the multicultural
incorporation of American Jews to an end,
or is this an alarmist
overreaction to what we should
instead regard as a
futile rear guard backlash
and a temporary aberration
from the multicultural
incorporation of American Jewry?
While the contemporary
resurgence of antisemitism
may seem to challenge Jeff's conclusions,
I argue instead that his
theorization of the multicultural
incorporation of American
Jews helps to explain
the resurgence of
antisemitism in two ways,
by highlighting the inherent instability
of the multicultural
mode of incorporation,
and by identifying new
problems of boundary definition
and identity that
multiculturalism generates.
If contemporary antisemitism
is a backlash against
multiculturalist trends
that began in the 1960s,
then it is a backlash that
arises from the very problems
then multiculturalism itself produces.
I will develop this thesis in four parts.
First, I'll briefly review
the three modes of civil incorporation
that Jeff has identified
and the distinctive relation
of Jews to civil society that
each of those modes entails.
Second, I will present evidence
for a resurgence of antisemitism
in the United States in
the past several years.
Third, I will trace the resurgence
of antisemitism in part to features
of the multicultural mode of incorporation
that Jeffrey Alexander has identified.
Fourth, I will provide additional support
for this interpretation if time permits
by means of a historical comparison
to cultural attitudes toward Jews
in the Calvinist or
Protestant reform tradition,
particularly among the Puritans,
and to be sure the Puritans
were not multiculturalists,
but they did identify themselves
with Jews to a remarkable degree,
and this identification
created similar problems
of boundary definition and identity,
which makes it, I think,
an instructive comparison.
So Jeffrey Alexander
examined the Jewish question
in relation to three ideal typical modes
by which excluded outgroups
have achieved incorporation
into the civil sphere.
The first of these modes
of incorporation historically
was assimilation,
which entails the separation
of the person who belongs
to an outgroup from the
stigmatized qualities
that distinguish the
outgroup from the core group.
That separation was typically accomplished
by means of a division between
private and public life.
Members of primordially
stigmatized groups could
participate in the discourse
and institutions of civil
society insofar as they
completely shed these identities
upon entering the public domain.
Assimilation is inclusionary,
in so far as it permits
the members of outgroups
to be evaluated positively
and thus affords them opportunities
for civic participation,
but it fails to challenge
the negative evaluation
of outgroup qualities.
Furthermore, as Jeffrey Alexander wrote,
because of its delicate and tense balance
between negatively evaluated qualities
and positively evaluated persons,
assimilation is a highly
unstable mode of incorporation.
The instabilities of the
assimilative mode of incorporation
allow it to be pushed
backward toward exclusion
or forward toward alternative
modes of civil incorporation.
The hyphenated mode of
incorporation began to emerge
in the United States at the
end of the 19th century,
turning immigrants and their descendants
into Polish Americans, Italian
Americans, and so forth.
Hyphenation is more open to,
and it accords more positive
recognition to foreign
or outsider particularities than does
the assimilative mode of incorporation.
Nevertheless, it remains fraught
with challenges for Jews
and other outgroups.
While ethnic particularities
remain evident
and pronounced, and this
mode of incorporation,
the qualities of excluded groups
are treated as complementary,
but still inferior to
those of the core group.
Alexander concluded
that the hyphenated mode
of incorporation like
the assimilative mode,
provides a highly unstable basis
for the expansion of civil solidarity,
and therefore is liable
to be pushed backward
to assimilation and even to exclusion
or else forward to the
multicultural mode of incorporation.
The multicultural mode of
incorporation goes further
and differs markedly from the assimilative
and hyphenated modes of incorporation
because it entails the positive evaluation
of outgroup qualities such as
peripheral national origins,
minority racial status,
or marginalized religion.
These primordial qualities
previously thought
to disqualify their bearers
from civil inclusion
become reinterpreted as
representing variations
on the sacred qualities of civility.
Following the dilemmas and
failures of the assimilative
and hyphenated modes of incorporation
earlier in the 20th century,
Alexander argued the
instabilities of Jewish American
incorporation were pushed
in a multicultural direction
from the 1960s onward.
Simply put,
Christian Americans began
to find Jewish qualities
attractive in themselves.
Alexander's evidence for this claim
was mainly drawn from
American popular culture,
including a close reading
of the self representations
of Jewish cultural producers
like the author Philip Roth and
the actor and director Woody Allen,
as well as demographic
trends like intermarriage.
According to this interpretation,
Christian Americans in
the post-war era came
to view the identity
of the previously
marginalized Jewish outgroup,
both as quote legitimately
and importantly different from their own.
And at the same time, as
fundamentally the same.
Unquote.
Multiculturalism, Alexander concluded,
requires and helps to
produce thicker and deeper
forms of mutual identification.
If American Jews begin to experience
a multicultural mode of
incorporation in the 1960s,
the country's erstwhile love affair
with Jewish qualities seems
to have taken a disturbing turn
for the worst in recent years.
The Anti-Defamation
Defamation League established
in 1913 to fight anti-Semitism
and other forms of
bigotry and discrimination
monitors anti-Semitic incidents
in the United States, including assaults,
vandalism, and harassment.
ADL reports indicate a steady decrease
in anti-Semitism from 2011 to 2013.
However,
the ADL reported a sharp rise
in antisemitic incidents in 2014.
This 21% increase from the
previous year was the first time
in nearly a decade of declines
where the overall number of
incidents substantially rose.
Anti-Semitic incidents
continued to increase in 2015
and then surged more
than one third in 2016,
particularly after November,
2016 when Donald Trump was
elected president of the United States,
the surge continued into
the first quarter of 2017,
jumping 86% during the first
three months of the new year.
The number of antisemitic incidents
in 2017 ultimately rose to 1,986,
a 57% rise from the previous year,
and the largest single
year increase on record,
and the second highest number reported
since the ADL started
tracking this data in 1979.
The number of anti-Semitic incidents
in the US fell slightly in 2018
before rising again in 2019.
Another record breaking year.
Rising anti-Semitism
was exemplified by the
2017 Unite the Right rally
in Charlottesville, Virginia,
where neo-Nazis chanted
Jews will not replace us,
and the murderous assault
on the Pittsburgh Tree of
Life Synagogue in 2018,
which the ADL described
as the deadliest attack
on the Jewish community in the
history of the United States.
The record number of anti-Semitic
incidents in 2019 included
deadly stabbings or shootings
of Jews at a rabbi's home
in Monte, New York, a kosher
grocery store, and Jersey City,
New Jersey, and a synagogue
in Poway, California.
Anti-Semitic incidents
declined slightly in 2020
and then reached an all time high
in 2021 that exceeded
even the 2019 levels.
And the other main
organization besides the ADL
that monitors anti-Semitic incidents
in the United States
is the Federal Bureau of Investigation.
The FBI tracks hate crimes defined
as an action of physical violence
or vandalism whose motive is a prejudice
against a specific group
and reports violence
against Jews under the category
of prejudice based on religion,
the pattern of anti-Jewish
hate crimes over time,
though lower in numbers
is roughly consistent
with the pattern in ADL data
on anti-Semitic incidents.
What we see here in this
graph is that the number
of anti-Jewish hate crime incidents
decreased steadily from 2011 through 2014.
The trend that the ADL welcomed, however,
anti-Jewish hate crime incidents started
to increase in 2015 rose again in 2016,
and spiked about 37% in 2017.
After following in 2018,
anti-Jewish hate crime
incidents jumped by 14% in 2019
when they comprised 13% of
all hate crime incidents,
despite Jews constituting less than 2%
of the US population
and fell again in 2020,
though they remained higher than levels
in the first half of the decade.
While data on hate crime incidents in 2021
and 2022 were not available
at the time this paper was prepared,
anti-Jewish hate crimes continued
to seize public attention
with the armed taking of hostages
at a synagogue in Colleyville,
Texas in January, 2022,
and the arrest just last
week of a man threatening
to kill Jewish government
officials in Michigan.
The rise in anti-Semitic
incidents and hate crimes
is associated with a shift
in cultural attitudes toward
Jews in the United States.
That's what I will argue at any rate,
and I think there are
worrying signs of such a shift
on both the political left
and the political right.
On the one hand,
the anti-Semitic motifs
of Jewish foreignness
or alienness exclusive
particularism, power,
and wickedness parallel or correspond
to anti-Zionist motifs that have appeared
in the discourse of some
self style progressives.
For example, US Representative Ilhan Omar
has at various times claimed that,
"Israel has hypnotized the
world while doing evil.
That congressional support for Israel
is quote all about the Benjamins."
That's to say all about money.
And that American supporters of Israel,
"Push for allegiance
to a foreign country."
Although Omar is widely
regarded as one of the most
progressive members of the US Congress,
these remarks earned her the praise
of former Ku Klux Klan
Grand Wizard David Duke.
The reason for this is
not hard to discern.
Omar's rhetoric corresponds
to at least two antisemitic motifs,
one, that money makes Jews powerful,
and the other the Jews are more loyal
to their own interests than the country
in which they're citizens.
Today, a segment of the American left
uses the counter Democratic code
and the discourse of civil society
to taint American Jews who
do not embrace anti-Zionism,
which is according to surveys,
most American Jews as bad Americans.
The shift in cultural attitudes
was strikingly displayed
by the surge of antisemitism
during the 2014 Israel Gaza conflict,
which went beyond mere
criticism of Israel or Zionism
to include assaults on Jewish individuals
and vandalism of Jewish institutions.
On the other hand,
under Donald Trump's
presidency from January,
2017 to January, 2021,
the term globalist spread
from far right anti-Semitic
websites into mainstream
civil and political discourse.
The use of the term as an
anti-Jewish dog whistle received
widespread attention in
2018 in connection with the
resignation of Trump's chief
economic advisor, Gary Cohen,
and the attempted bombing
of the philanthropist George
Soros' home in New York.
As Aryeh Tuchman from the
Anti-Defamation League noted,
the application of the
term to Jews carries
a host of associations that cannot
be extricated from the
history of anti-Semitism.
Tuchman linked the term to
long-running conspiracy theories
about Jewish populations not
being loyal to the countries
they live in and cooperating
through secret international alliances.
The anti-global representation
of Jews is in some ways
antithetical to the
anti-Zionist representation.
Are Jews cosmopolitans or
nationalists we might ask.
Nevertheless, the two discourses converge
in constructing Jews as disloyal
to the United States, secretive, powerful,
and above all, anti-civil.
The multicultural
incorporation of American Jews
that began in the 1960s makes
the recent resurgence of antisemitism
appear surprising and perplexing.
While claims of multicultural
incorporation seem hard
to square with evidence
of rising antisemitism,
I will argue that Alexander's theorization
of multiculturalism reveals
some of the processes that underlie
this partial reversal.
Since, as Alexander makes clear,
the multicultural mode of
incorporation does not represent
the end of an inevitable developmental
or evolutionary logic,
there's no reason to expect
it to remain permanent.
As Alexander conceives it.
Multiculturalism involves
the paradoxical perception
of difference as a
variation on shared humanity
or the perception of outgroups
as legitimately and importantly
different from the core group,
yet fundamentally in some sense, the same.
This paradox he suggests
generates problems of boundary
definition and identity that
make the multicultural mode of
incorporation unstable in its own way.
What Alexander means by this becomes clear
in his discussion of the
paradoxical consequences
of multicultural incorporation
for American Jews.
Christian America's multicultural
embrace of Jewish qualities allowed,
he wrote "Confident assertions
of Jewish difference,
including a return to
traditional religious practices
and non-orthodox synagogues,
the growth of Jewish day schools
and the creation of
Jewish studies departments
and programs at American universities."
Yet Jewish assertions of
difference were accompanied
by Jewish anxiety about
the continuing viability
of Judaism in America.
The seemingly unwarranted
anxiety was a response
to the problems of boundary definition
and identity that the multicultural
mode of incorporation generates.
And here I'm quoting Jeffrey Alexander.
If difference can be
recognized only when there
is increasing solidarity
between core and outgroup,
it should not be surprising that even
as they begin to cultivate
their differences,
Jewish Americans would come to feel
more like non-Jewish
Americans and the latter,
more like them.
In Alexander's account,
it's precisely this mutual
identification that creates
anxiety about the loss of a
distinctive Jewish identity.
Rising antisemitism in the
United States may reflect
the problems of boundary definition
and identity that Alexander
associated with multiculturalism,
but in a different way
than he anticipated.
If mutual identification
encourages Jewish anxiety
about the continuing viability
of Judaism in America,
then it is likely to foster
an analogous reaction
among Americans with a Christian heritage.
In other words,
to the extent that core
group and outgroup identities
are viewed as fundamentally the same,
the non-Jewish core group
will also experience anxiety
about the continuing viability
of its own identity and perhaps
even the national identity
with which the core group
has been historically closely associated.
One way this anxiety finds expression
is in a renewed antisemitism,
and especially antisemitic
efforts to reestablish
hierarchical boundaries
that multiculturalism
threatens to dissolve.
If the multicultural mode
of incorporation generates problems
of boundary definition and
identity for the core group,
as well as for American Jews,
there's no reason to
think that these problems
will be limited to core group members
who are committed to one or
another political ideology.
The problems may, however,
appear in somewhat different guises
as a result of these
political commitments.
On the one hand,
breaking with the historical
self consecration of
the American core group,
some core group members aligned
with the progressive left
are now inclined to view the core group
as a deeply anti-civil oppressor
of minorities and outgroups.
This trans valuation of the core group
by some of its own members,
has adverse consequences
for the Jewish outgroup
when Jews are perceived to
be fundamentally the same.
Instead of viewing American
Jews as a marginalized outgroup
that deserves their solidarity
or allyship in contemporary
political parlance,
these core group members find
it hard to distinguish Jews
from other quote unquote powerful
and privileged core group members.
These core group members continue
to see Israel as a little America,
but their trans valuation
of the American core group
now makes this identification polluting.
Rather than interpreting Jewishness
as a variation on the sacred
qualities of civility,
these core group members
may instead come to see it
as a variation on the profane
qualities of incivility.
From there,
I would say it's a small step to transfer
their guilt to the Jews, their
tolerance, normalization,
or in rare instances expression.
Outright expressions of antisemitism,
I would say is the bad
conscience of the core group.
On the other hand,
core group members on the
far right try to maintain
restrictive primordial
definitions of civility
or even to make those
definitions more narrower.
Some of these core
group members blame Jews
for multiculturalism, for immigration,
and other developments that they think
threaten the American core group.
Nevertheless, they identify Jew,
they identify with Jews
in surprising ways,
attributing to them, and
ethnocentric culture,
which they believe advantages Jews
and is at odds with the multiculturalism
that they believe Jews foist on others.
Their hatred of Jews is in
this way conjoined with envy.
This perspective shapes
attitudes toward Israel as well.
For instance, in 2017,
the white nationalist Richard
Spencer described himself
to an Israeli journalist
as a "White Zionist",
and insisted to the journalist that,
"You should respect someone
like me who understands
your identity and the
experience of the Jewish people,
and has analog feelings about whites."
Notwithstanding Spencer's spurious analogy
and distorted understanding of Zionism,
these comments reveal the
ambivalence of core group members
on the far right who see Jews as a threat
and simultaneously project
their own wishes onto them.
The portrait of the Jews that they offer
to the world is in fact
their own self-portrait.
This theoretical argument
about the American core group
and its relation to
Jews needs qualification
in a few key respects,
and so I wanna mention those here.
First, I don't want to suggest,
and I don't mean to suggest
that the entire American core
group has become anti-Semitic.
Rather, problems of boundary definition
and identity facilitate
tolerance, normalization,
or even outright
expressions of anti-Semitism
among core group members
making such expressions
more likely within the group.
Second, Christianity is only
one of the primordial qualities
available for defining
the American core group
and judging civil competence.
Nevertheless, following Alexander,
the Christian qualities
analytically accentuated here
because of its particular significance
vis-a-vis the Jewish outgroup.
And third, while this theoretical argument
is about the core group
in its relation to Jews,
it raises questions about
the growing minority
of Americans who are
religiously unaffiliated,
which according to survey
research now make up
about 29% of all Americans,
as well as the very small
minority of Americans
who are religiously affiliated,
but belong neither to America's
historically Christian core group,
nor to the Jewish outgroup
and survey data suggests
that those Americans make up
about 4% of the population.
Many religiously
unaffiliated Americans belong
to the Christian core
group by cultural heritage.
Even if they do not identify as Christian,
they may have no use for
Christianity as church or credo,
but its cultural influence endures
in the form of secularized Christianity.
They're therefore likely I
would submit to share in some
form the anxieties that
the multicultural mode of
incorporation generates among
other core group members.
However, the anxieties of
someone like Ilhan Omar
would be more complicated.
Since Muslim Americans have arguably
not experienced a multicultural
mode of incorporation,
their identities may be
more divided in a manner
characteristic of hyphenation
or even double consciousness.
In addition, the relative success
of the multicultural incorporation
of Jewish Americans since the 1960s
may lead such minorities
to resent an outgroup
that they perceive to have
joined the core group.
In my view, this is a mistaken perception,
and it's mistaken, I
think for a few reasons.
One, even in ideal typical form,
multiculturalism does not
simply absorb outgroups
into an expanded core group.
Rather, outgroups are
paradoxically perceived
as both legitimately and
importantly different
from the core group, and
as fundamentally the same.
Second, the multicultural
mode of incorporation
takes incomplete or uneven
forms in real civil societies,
in part because it
overlaps with past modes
of incorporation that partly
survive into the present.
And third, and this in a way,
is part of the point of this paper
as a whole renewed antisemitism,
belies the assumption that Jews
are now part of the American core group
in any simple or straightforward sense.
Let me turn to the last
part of my paper here,
and I hope you'll indulge
me with this excursus,
the multicultural mode
of civil incorporation is quite new
in the history of Western societies.
Nevertheless, I think historical analogies
can still be instructive.
Despite the millennia-long
Christian pollution of Jews
as incapable of participating
in the civic life of Christian societies,
we can find exceptional
cases in which members
of a Christian core group identified
in relatively thick and deep
ways with the Jewish outgroup.
Such identification usually involve
a positive evaluation of
not only Jewish persons,
but also some Jewish qualities
such as chosenness and biblical truth.
And these instances,
some Christians came
to see Jewish identity
as importantly different
from the core groups,
and at the same time as
fundamentally the same,
their views anticipated
multiculturalism in this respect,
even if Christian theological
assumptions prevented
their views from developing
fully in this direction,
cultural attitudes toward
Jews in the Calvinist
or Protestant reformed tradition,
particularly among the Puritans,
may provide the best example.
Puritanism always felt its
inner similarity to Judaism,
Max Faber wrote, even if it also felt
the limits of the similarity.
Consequently, I will suggest Puritans
experienced problems
of boundary definition
and identity similar to those
generated by multiculturalism,
and they manage the
resulting anxieties in ways
that illuminate the
contemporary resurgence
of antisemitism in the United States.
The Protestant Reformation
in the 16th century gave rise
to intense religious conflicts
and sectarian struggles among Christians
in which each faction frequently
accused the others of Judaism.
For example, a Bavarian Catholic preached
in a 1551 sermon that the king of England,
at that time, the Protestant Edward VI,
his council and Kingdom
had all become Jews.
The Church of England
soon turned the charge
against its own internal dissenters
labeling Puritans as judaizers
in the late 16th century
in the association
between Puritanism and
Judaism was formally
in place as the 17th century got underway.
But in this instance,
the charge was more than a stigmatizing
label used to discredit rivals.
The Puritans were convinced
that they were the true Jews,
the ultimate and total
heirs of the promises
that God had made in the Hebrew Bible,
and the strong identification
expressed itself
in a variety of judaizing
practices summarized
by the historian Eliana Glazer,
and I'm quoting Glazer here.
Puritans attempted to strip
away what they regarded
as corrupt layers of Episcopal authority
and popish ceremonial and reclaimed
the original apostolic Christian faith.
They justified their position
by invoking the Bible,
and particularly the Old Testament,
and they believed that
scripture should be read
in the original Hebrew.
Puritans advocated the use of
Hebrew in biblical translation
and scriptural exegesis,
and they identified with
the biblical chosen people.
In addition, many puritans
became scholars of
post-biblical Jewish literature
such as the Talmud, and
most heterodox of all,
some even began to adopt Jewish practices
and customs such as the
Sabbath and Passover.
Puritan identification
with Jews created problems
of boundary definition
and identity analogous
to those that arise in multiculturalism,
which fueled anxiety about
the continuing viability
of their own religious identity.
The Puritans consequently
tried to reassert boundaries
that have become obscured, and
this is evident, for example,
in conflicts over whether
to readmit Jews into England
and whether to admit them into
the Massachusetts Bay Colony.
The debate in 1655 to 1656
over whether to readmit Jews
into England following their expulsion
in 1290 was shaped in part
by Puritan Semitism and Arianism.
The public practices
of Christian judaizers
and the growth of interest in Hebrew
had already helped to put Jews
in a favorable light among
Protestant reformers,
some of whom came to believe
that the return of Jews
to England would hasten the
second coming of Christ.
Not surprisingly then,
some of the most strident
devotees of the mid 17th century
Puritan Revolution favored
readmission of Jews.
The historian Roger Healy
suggests that the readmission
movement failed because
not enough English believed
that the Jews were future Christians
and harbingers of the millennium.
However, opposition to the readmission
of Jews also sprang from a deeper fear,
namely that it would result
in the utilization of Christians,
and thus the loss of a
distinctive Christian identity.
Among religious leaders,
there were many who liked
the Puritan pamphleteer,
William Prin,
believed that if the Jews were readmitted,
the Christians "Would sooner turn Jews
than the Jews Christians."
One response to this boundary crisis was
to keep Jews out of England.
The symbolic logic is
apparent, for example,
in the writings of the 17th century
political philosopher James Harrington.
Although Harrington advocated
a theocratic republic in England,
modeled on the Hebrew commonwealth,
established through Moses
fear of judaization led him
to oppose the readmission of Jews.
He proposed instead,
the establishment of a
colony of Jews in Ireland
where they could be
profitable to the republic,
but safely separate from it.
As the sociologist Kai Erikson points out
in his classic study of
deviance in Puritan New England,
communities maintain their boundaries
in geographical as well as cultural space.
And here I'm quoting Erikson,
"Both of these dimensions of group space,
the geographical and the cultural,
set the community apart as a special place
and provide an important
point of reference for its members."
And the debate over
readmission of Jews to England,
maintenance of geographical
boundaries served
to compensate for the obscuring
of cultural boundaries.
Like the English Puritans,
their counterparts in New
England similarly struggled
to redefine boundaries
that their philosemitism
threatened to dissolve.
To be sure identification
with Jews was not the only source
of boundary definition
and identity problems
in the new world.
But Puritan identification
with Jews threatened
to obscure the cultural boundaries
of the Puritan community
in its own way and compounded anxiety
about the continuing viability
of Puritanism in America.
Erikson analyzed the
Antinomian controversy of 1636,
the Quaker persecutions of the late 1650s,
and the witchcraft hysteria
of 1692 as different attempts
by the people of the Massachusetts Bay
to clarify their position
in the world as a whole,
to redefine the boundaries
which set New England apart
as a new experiment in living.
The inhospitable and
exclusionary practices
that New England Puritans adopted
toward the handful of
Jews they encountered
in the 17th century may be
understood in the same way,
although New England
Puritans persecuted Quakers
more severely than Jews,
exclusion of Jews was rooted
in the same symbolic quandary.
Here I'm quoting Erikson,
it was exactly because the
New England Puritans shared
so many features in
common with the Quakers,
that they had to publicize
the few crucial differences
as noisily as they could to mark
off a new set of boundaries
for the New England way.
They had to make a particular
effort to emphasize
those points where the Puritan
and Quaker streams diverged.
The New England Puritans
treatment of the Jews
they encountered events,
an analogous effort to mark
off boundaries and keep
a group with whom they shared
many features safely separate.
So in some puritans were
not multiculturalists,
but they did identify with
Jews to an unusual degree.
And this identification
generated problems of boundary
definition and identity
similar to those that arise
from the multicultural
mode of incorporation.
Consequently, the Puritans
experienced anxiety
about the continuing viability
of their religious movement and the loss
of their own distinctive
religious identity.
If they saw Jews as future Christians,
they also worried that they
themselves might become Jews.
The closer their identification with Jews,
the more they found it necessary
to keep Jews at arm's length.
As the boundaries that set Puritanism
apart threatened to become more obscure.
They strove to mark off
a new set of boundaries
by excluding Jews from the geographical
or cultural space that
the community occupied.
And this history,
I would submit finds it's parallel
and contemporary fears
that Jewish Zionists
and globalists are
figuratively judaizing America,
and in anti-Semitic
efforts to exclude Jews
from the civil sphere.
To conclude, while there is
persuasive evidence of a shift,
beginning in the 1960s toward
a multicultural mode of
incorporation for American Jews,
the resurgence of
antisemitism in recent years
in the form of a sharp rise
in antisemitic incidents,
as well as changing patterns
of discourse and cultural
representation underscores
the instability of this
mode of incorporation.
After a half century of multicultural
incorporation of American Jews.
How and why is antisemitism
now on the rise?
A theory that posits the
multicultural incorporation
of American Jews would seem
to have difficulty explaining the
revival of antisemitism.
But in fact, Jeffrey Alexander's analysis
of multiculturalism
provides important clues
for understanding its partial reversal.
His analysis acknowledged the instability
of the multicultural mode of incorporation
and traced it to the new
problems of boundary definition
and identity that
multiculturalism generates.
According to Alexander,
these problems explained why
American Jews felt anxiety
about the continuing viability
of Judaism in America,
despite an unparalleled
embrace of Jewish qualities
by the Christian core group.
What I have argued here
today is that these problems
of boundary definition and identity
also generate corresponding anxieties
among members of the Christian core group,
and these anxieties are
contributing to the resurgence
of antisemitism and the
United States today.
Thanks very much.
- Oh, thank you very much, Chad.
I'm not able to get myself
on the screen at this point,
but you can hear me, right?
Yes.
- There we go.
And I will answer to them.
I will ask them for you to chat.
Well, one question that might be helpful
to answer is
by David Foreign.
He asks, what is boundary definition?
- Yeah, so I mean,
I am drawing here on Jeff's work,
but also in the work of Kai
Erikson and some others,
all of whom sort of
emphasized the importance,
to groups and communities
of having clear boundaries
that set the identities
of those groups apart,
that distinguish them
in some way and allow
the members of those groups to
consecrate their identities,
their ways of life, their
practices as somehow special,
distinctive,
and worthy of difference.
So I guess what I would say then
is that the boundary definition has
to do with how any community,
any cultural group distinguishes
itself from others,
how it defines itself,
and any process of self-definition
is going to involve
a process of distinction
that it's going to,
in some way set itself apart from others,
not necessarily,
I think, in an insidious way.
And I don't think that
this kind of boundary work
is inherently bad or
detrimental to other groups.
I think it's just part of
how identity formation works.
So that's what I have in mind
when I talk about boundary definition.
I hope that makes it a little bit clearer.
- Yes, that's important
for non-sociologists
to get some of the terms out there.
Here's another question
for you from Rena Seltzer.
She asked, how does the woke ideology,
which promotes antisemitism
by defining Jews as privileged oppressors,
and through intersectionality
defining Zionism
and Israel as colonialists,
how does this woke ideology
fit into your schema?
- Yeah, so I, you know,
I think there's a lot of debate about
this term and what it means,
and people use it in different ways.
Some people use it very broadly.
Some people use it in sort
of more specific ways.
I think I touched on this when
I talked about members of,
again, not all members of the core group,
but some members of the
core group who have,
who have been involved,
in what we could describe
as a trans valuation of
the core group itself.
So again, the point that I tried to make,
and maybe I went through this
a little bit too quickly,
and maybe it was lost,
is that what to me is a
really interesting process
sociologically and culturally,
is that you have people that are,
I think members of the core
group, not exclusively,
but some of them are core group members
or have that cultural heritage
who have come to regard the core group
that they belong to as deeply anti-civil.
And so what I suggested is that this is,
my argument is less about the ideology.
So I think the roots of
antisemitism lie less in ideology
than in these new problems
of boundary definition and identity.
This term that I borrowed from Jeff's work
in his and civil sphere theory,
which are really sort of
cultural and structural problems
generated by the multicultural
mode of incorporation.
So my argument is not really
about the effects of ideology.
I think maybe the way that ideology,
political ideologies come into play here
is that they mediate and they shape
how members of the core group make
sense of these anxieties
and how they respond to these anxieties.
And so there, I think
we see some variation,
but I don't think that
antisemitism is a product
of one and only one political ideology.
I think there's a variety of ideologies
that we can find in the American
political landscape today.
And I'm struck and worried by what I see
as expressions of antisemitism
or at least tolerance of antisemitism
on different sides of the political divide
in the political spectrum.
So, there is a connection,
but I wouldn't say,
and I don't argue in this paper
that a political ideology,
woke or otherwise, is the
source of these problems.
- Thank you.
Now we have a question kind
of from the opposite side.
This is anonymous.
So he says, why in
anti-Semitism historically
has been correlated with
an income inequality and social unrest,
given the extreme income
inequality in America today,
do you think this plays or has played
a role in the rise of anti-Semitism?
- Yeah, interesting.
I think so.
I think the roots of antisemitism
are multiple and complex.
I think that there can be a conjuncture
of different factors at work,
and I think the globalist language
that I talked about is maybe a way in
which anxiety's about
growing economic inequality
get linked to antipathy
or hostility toward Jews.
And so this is a longstanding
feature of antisemitism.
When you look at this,
Jews have been blamed or associated
with the power of finance,
with the power of money.
You see this also, I
mentioned in the talk,
the way that this comes out
in some anti-Zionist tropes,
where again, this, the power
of money is emphasized,
and I've provided some examples of that.
And so this sort of parallels
or corresponds to how these tropes
have been used in
relationship to Jews directly.
So I think it is a factor.
I think it's a contributing factor.
I think it's linked with the factors
that I emphasized or that I focused
on in complicated ways.
But I do think it is
part of what's going on.
The interesting question
to me is, you know,
economic inequality has
been growing for decades,
and yet antisemitism was on the decline
until much more recently.
And so if you would say, well,
antisemitism is basically a response
to growing economic inequality,
what then explains the timing?
Why is it so delayed
given that inequalities
have been deepening for many years?
So that's why I think by itself,
this is not really a
sufficient explanation,
but also, it seems to me
that it would have to be,
it would have to be
taken into consideration
for any kind of comprehensive
account of antisemitism today.
- Great.
This is a very good series of exchanges.
Now I'm gonna speak,
for Mari Samuel's question
after complimenting you
for a great talk, quote.
He asked this,
my question is how you account
for the fact that antisemitism
is rising globally,
including in countries like France,
which have not followed the same pattern
of multiculturalism as in the US.
- Interesting.
Yeah.
So the argument that I
develop here is specifically
about the US,
and I think that's a good question.
I think we need more, you know,
I am sort of a comparative as well
as a historical sociologist.
And so I think we need sort
of more comparative research
because I a agree with
Mari that this is something
that we see in many
countries around the world.
And what it suggests to me is that, again,
that there are multiple factors at work.
I'm reminded here of
William Brustein's book
"The Roots of Hate",
which really try to get at these sort
of multiple manifestations of antisemitism
and the different forms that it took in
the different sources of antisemitism
that sometimes come together,
I think in the European context.
Yeah, I don't know how far I wanna go in.
So I guess two things
I wanna say about this.
Maybe I, you know,
I hesitate to say too
much because I haven't,
this is a question that I'm
not sure about the incident,
and I think this requires more research,
so I hesitate to say too much.
But I wanna say two things.
First of all, I forgot to mention this
at the beginning of my talk.
This paper I wanna say is part,
I should have mentioned this before.
It's part of a symposium
that's forthcoming
in the American Journal
of Cultural Sociology.
And those papers,
I think provide some of
this comparative framing
that you don't get in this paper alone.
So my paper is focused
on the US in particular.
There's another paper that Jeff
and Tracy Adams contributed
to that symposium,
which is really comparative in nature
and tries to develop
a kind of theorization
about comparative variations that we see
in expressions of antisemitism.
And I think does it really insightfully
actually in a way that's both
historical and comparative.
And then the third set in those,
the third paper there deals
with the Scandinavian countries.
So you, you get a kind of
cross-national perspective
on antisemitism.
And the other thing
that I was gonna say is
I don't know how widespread this view is,
but I am struck by the perspective
of some European born intellectuals.
I'm thinking of people like Alain Badiou
Matty Bonzo and Enzo
Traverso who have insisted
that Jews are now part of the core group,
that after the Shah Jews
became privileged insiders
in European societies in Western Europe,
privileged insiders of a
dominant Judeo-Christian European
or Western order at the
expense of new outgroups,
particularly Muslims.
I'm quite skeptical of
that argument myself,
but I think that if I
were going to explore
the roots of antisemitism in countries
like France and other European countries,
I would wanna make this
part of the analysis.
I would wanna try to
understand to what extent
this view is widely held
and to what extent this view contributes
to images of Jews as
in the current political conjuncture,
reactionary and anti-civil.
So this would be something
I would wanna explore further, I think.
But I don't have a very good
answer to your question,
Mari, because I haven't done
the comparative work myself.
- Okay, now this is a question
from that kind of relates
to this discussion from Diane Louie.
Does the anxiety regarding
boundary definition presuppose
that the excluded group
retains inferiority
in the mind of the core group?
That is, is there a pervasive
stigma in the core group
in being perceived as
having intersectionality
with the excluded group?
- Jeff, can you read that one more time?
I'm not sure I fully
understood the question.
- I don't understand the last sentence,
but let me just repeat the first sentence
'cause I do think you can address that.
Does the anxiety regarding
boundary definitions presuppose
that the excluded group
retains inferiority
in the mind of the core group?
In other words,
I think they mean as it's
being incorporated speaks
to what you had just talked about.
- Yeah, yeah.
I wouldn't put it that way.
You know, because I
think what is distinctive
about the multicultural mode of
incorporation as I
understand it, is that those,
those outgroup qualities that
were perceived as stigmatizing
the past become increasingly
destigmatized and even admired.
I think what that does,
it does fuel anxieties about
identity and boundaries
and sort of definitions
of sort of the core group.
And among some core group members,
I think that leads to an
effort to reassert hierarchical
boundaries that multiculturalism
intends to dissolve.
So I would put it a
little bit differently.
I think this is not quite how
I would understand things.
- Okay.
I'm gonna now translate
a question from Yada de Leon.
Could you expand on how
other outgroup communities,
especially black American communities,
contribute to and or push back
against this resurgence of antisemitism?
I'm especially interested
in hearing more about
the resentment aspect
that you'd mentioned.
- Yeah, yeah.
Also an interesting question.
You know, again, here I
can be only tentative,
you know, I haven't done,
I haven't done the work, you know,
the research that you know, would allow me
to speak really
authoritatively about this.
My sense, my impression is
that within other outgroup communities,
there is sometimes probably
a feeling of resentment
to other outgroups that are
perceived to be more successful.
But I think that I don't think
that it would be fair to say that that
sort of is the be all
and in all of attitudes
in those other outgroup communities,
there's also the possibility and sometimes
the realization of solidarity
among those outgroups.
Even when those act groups
have sort of different relative degrees
of sort of successful
multicultural incorporation.
And I'm thinking in particular,
I'm thinking in particular of an incident
that happened on my own
campus several years ago.
There was an anti-Semitic
incident on campus.
There was a kind of,
sort of a teaching that was held about it.
And I remember the teaching
was attended by lots of students.
Some of them were Jewish,
some of them were non-Jewish,
and some of them were African-American.
And initially the
discussion sort of started
to fall into this groove
that you sometimes see
in these kinds of
conversations about sort of
who has suffered more historically.
And I think these discussions
are always kind of pointless.
I don't think they really
ever serve anybody well.
Also, I dunno how you would sort
of quantify degrees of suffering.
And so it sort of went in
that direction initially.
But by the end of the evening,
I was struck that some of the same people
who had sort of begun this way,
had moved to a different way of talking
and had begun to identify with each other
in a way that they,
I think maybe didn't at the
beginning of the evening
and had begun to sort of identify
some commonalities in their experiences.
So their experiences were
by no means identical.
I don't wanna suggest that they are,
but they began to see some commonalities
and they began to see each other not
as sort of competitors
in terms of, you know,
claiming the title of
who has been most wronged historically,
but as people who shared
not identical conditions,
not identical situations,
but situations with enough
elements shared in common
that they could begin to perceive
a way of working together
to move the campus
in a more inclusive direction
and to work together to do that.
And I'd like to think
that it's still possible.
I do think that it's
still possible though,
I think for a variety of reasons
there's many forces at work
in American society today
that make that hard and difficult.
But this too,
I think remains a real possibility
that is sometimes realized
and practiced in American society.
- Okay.
Here are two more.
I'd say specific questions
from Laz Schneider.
First, to what extent are anti-Semitic
incidents related to Islamic issues,
especially regarding in
relationship to Israel or otherwise?
For example, Omar,
to what can the increased black
anti-Semitism be attributed?
- I mean, again, an interesting question.
So my focus has been on the core group,
on the American core group.
And so this is really a question
about groups outside of the core.
This in a way,
I think relates to Mari's
question about France.
So, you know, so if the question is about
antisemitism within Muslim
communities in the United States,
I have no doubt that it exists.
But I think this is a
much less of a problem
in the United States than it
is in a place like France.
Because Muslims as a percentage
of the population in the United States,
it's a much lower
percentage of the population
in the US than it is in France.
So I don't see Muslims as the sort
of primary source of
antisemitism in this country.
For one thing, there's not enough of them
in order for them to play this role.
And so this is what I would
say about the Islamic issues,
you know, in terms of sort
of Muslims and blacks,
you know, again, we're
talking about other outgroups,
and here I, you know,
I can simply repeat what I
said on the paper about this,
that I think we have to distinguish
the sources when antisemitism
does arise within other outgroups,
we have to distinguish
the factors at work,
the dynamics there from the core group,
because I think the
dynamics are different.
And I think sometimes
there is a kind of politics of resentment
that is at work here.
But I also think that
an analysis of the degree
to which antisemitism exists
in these communities also has
to take into consideration
the way in which
the multicultural incorporation
of these groups has been less successful.
And this is, yeah,
well, I'll just leave it there for now.
- Thank you.
Here is another specific question.
I think we're beginning to wrap up.
What is this,
what is the relationship
between anti-Semitism
and anti-Israel sentiments,
I.e. the critical view of what the state
of Israel has been doing to Arabs?
To me, it seems paradoxical
that alt-right figures like Trump
are somehow supportive
of the Israeli government
while instigating anti-Semitic
sentiments themselves.
- Yeah, yeah.
Another great question.
I, you know, I would make a distinction.
I would want to make a distinction
between criticism of Israel.
And right now, I think, and I'm speaking,
you know, just personally
not as a, you know,
this is not a sociological statement.
This is a personal statement right now.
I think there's a lot to criticize
in the current government in Israel.
I would distinguish
that from anti-Zionism,
and anti-Zionism I would
think of as a kind of,
as yet another kind of
political ideology in which
the existence of a Jewish
national homeland in Palestine
is considered illegitimate,
that it was illegitimate
from the beginning, remains illegitimate.
And so this is a different,
I think different kind of thing.
I am certainly not somebody who thinks
that criticism of Israel is inherently,
or by definition, anti-Semitic.
I don't even think that anti-Zionism
is inherently anti-Semitic,
although I think there's a lot of overlap
between anti-Zionism
and anti-Semitism today.
And the way that I tend to
think about this is a way
that here I'm influenced
by Mitchell Cohen,
who wrote a piece in
2003 along these lines,
who talked about the ways that
anti-Zionist discourses ways of talking,
ways of thinking,
position Zionist or Israel
in ways analogous to how
antisemitism positions Jews.
And that I actually think
Cohen was onto something.
I think there's a lot
of evidence for that.
And that's what I tried to
suggest in the paper as well.
- Okay, I'm gonna ask you
really two more questions,
and then we'll call it a day.
By David Silverberg.
It's a pretty long question,
but I think it's an interesting one.
He says he's piggybacking
off a previous answer
about Jewish incorporation
into the dominant group,
Alain Badiou, et cetera.
He says, I have a question
about where the reassertion of whiteness
as the primary defining sociological frame
in the United States fits in.
This seems important because one,
whiteness in the US is obviously unstable.
There's a ton of work on the incorporation
of different ethnic
groups across disciplines.
And two, because Unite
the Right event raised
in this presentation clearly is hostile,
not just towards Jews,
but to many other groups
based on whiteness.
So how are you factoring or not factoring
in whiteness as an in-group identity?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have sort of bracketed
the question in this paper.
So, you know, and I
think really addressing
this in the detail and
depth that it needs to be,
would require a paper of its own.
And there's a lot being
written about this.
I agree with the points
about whiteness being something unstable.
The boundaries of whiteness have, we know,
have been contested and
shifted over time historically,
there is,
so we know that.
I would also say that whiteness
is another one of these sort
of primordial qualities by which
the American core group has
historically been defined.
And the relationship of Jews to whiteness
is sort of interesting one,
Eric Goldstein and others have written
about this very perceptively.
I think this would have to be part
of a wider conversation
about core group and its relationship
to outgroups in American history.
But maybe the last thing
I'll say about this is that
one of the things that
sometimes bothers me
about these sort of discussions
about Jews and whiteness is,
I have a feeling sometimes
that these discussions become,
they start to revolve around
the question of whether Jews are white,
whether Jews have ever been white,
when did they become white,
are they still white?
Who has the authority
to define Jews racially?
And those are interesting questions,
but what I worry about,
I guess, is that,
in a way,
I have a feeling that
these discussions sometimes
in a kind of Procrustean fashion,
try to squeeze Jews into other categories.
And I'm always struck by the fact
that antisemitism is something
that Jews can suffer from
and be victimized by,
regardless of their
racial status of whether
they're sort of perceived and
defined as as white or not.
And I think this sometimes
gets lost in these discussions.
It sort of falls by the wayside
when the discussion comes,
starts to be focused exclusively on color.
And well, if we had more time, you know,
I would invoke some things
that Dubois wrote late
in his life and late in his career
about the Jewish question
where he sort of acknowledged
that early in his career
he tended to think of race,
racism, racial conflict
exclusively in terms of color.
And later came to see that
it was a more multifaceted
and more complicated kind
of social phenomenon.
And I tend to agree with
Dubois on on this point.
I think those kinds of things
get, sometimes get lost,
not necessarily, but sometimes get lost
when the conversation shifts to questions
about whiteness in the
relationship of Jews to whiteness.
- Thanks.
I'm gonna ask you the last
question then add on something
from me which relates to that.
Michael Alnik asks,
do trends in anti-Semitic
incidents and hate crimes
necessarily index trends in anti-Semitism
among the general American population?
And I think that's a good question,
and I was thinking that
whether the indexing,
you saw the disturbing index
and we're all aware of it,
of anti-Semitic incidents and hate crimes,
and I think you know this
from my own paper in our symposium,
but does this indicate an
increase in anti-Semitic beliefs
or an increase in public
anti-Semitic actions?
In other words, a kind of disinhibition,
which doesn't mean that
there's an increase
of anti-Semitic beliefs.
I don't want to, you know,
black out the first question.
I think they're related to each other.
- Yeah, yeah.
Well first I'll just say hello to Michael.
Michael is a friend and colleague,
so it's great that you're
able to be here, Michael.
So I focused on incidents
for a couple of reasons.
You know, data on incidents
are readily available.
They're sort of organizations
that are collecting this data,
and number one, number two,
I'm enough of a pragmatist to think that
beliefs that don't have
practical consequences
are perhaps less interesting.
And so,
and I think that's a sort of
a view that many people would hold.
So of course we're concerned
about anti-Semitic beliefs,
but we're most concerned
about those beliefs
when they find expression
in anti-Semitic action
or anti-Semitic practices.
The question of whether these incidents
indicates a growth in beliefs or simply
a weakening of the prohibitions against
acting on those beliefs or expressing
those beliefs is an interesting one.
I don't know the answer to that question.
And I think the data that I have here,
that I used in this paper
and that I presented
this paper doesn't allow
us to answer that question.
I think the ADL and some
other Jewish groups are trying
to get at the beliefs question
more directly with survey data.
And the problem with that is if
you wanna see how these beliefs
sort of change over time,
you need a kind of
longitudinal study, right?
So it's not enough to have a snapshot
of what the beliefs are this year.
It doesn't tell us much if we don't
know what the beliefs were,
what they looked like five years ago
or 10 years ago or 25 years ago.
And I'm not sure there's really
good longitudinal data about that.
Maybe there is.
I'm not sure that there is,
so I think it's an important question.
It's a question that I'll say that
I don't know the answer to,
and I think it requires more research.
- Chad, I wanna thank you for
this very stimulating paper
about a subject that is
immensely depressing,
but your talk was not depressing,
but inspiring and your
open-minded response
to the questions has been just great.
So thank you very much on behalf
of this community and we look forward.
- Thank you, Jeff.
- Your work in the future.
- Thanks so much.
- Okay.
Bye, everybody.